who knew marxists knew the markets
patrice khan coulres co-founder of black
lives matter allegedly purchased four
homes
in the past few years yep she's just
another person the trump administration
made rich
but who knew conflict paid so well
what's next the founder of antifa
putting a bid on a condo at the top of
trump towers
but i got to tell you it ain't bad for a
trained marxist
am i a marxist i'm a lot of things i do
believe in marxism it's a philosophy
that i learned really
early on in my organizing career we were
taught
to learn about the systems that were
criticizing capitalism how exactly do
you train a marxist
public schools would love suggestions
and what's the skill
set making molotov cocktails and knowing
how to burn a flag i could do that
so what does that tell you about america
in general
that were awesome only in a free market
capitalist society can a marxist
actually get rich it's a salute to all
of us
that she figured this out and i'm kind
of jealous her business school is
watching eight sopranos episodes
according to dirk.com which focuses on
real estate and not pete hex's hygiene
she bought a 1.4 million dollar compound
she also bought a house for a half a
million in 2016 which is now worth 800k
today a 600 grand house in south la
that's now worth 720.
so i guess homes in the suburbs were
cheaper before the cities were set on
fire so marxists aren't just good at
killing but making a killing
which really doesn't make her a marxist
at all we went to socialist bernie
sanders
who only has three homes
for a comment how in the world does she
have
four homes i have three i think i have
three i can't remember
i'm an idiot i should have been a
communist not a socialist
i would be rolling in the dome i could
go for a roll right now
oh crap there's a bird stuck in my hair
leave me alone
oh those are actual birds i hope he's
okay
she also bought a ranch in georgia that
has a private airplane hangar
i guess it's the only way global warming
activists can visit
and the new york post also says she's
eyeing property in the bahamas at a
resort where both justin timberlake and
tiger woods have homes
you know the lump in proletariat that's
exciting she'll be living next door to a
singer who can't act and a golfer who
can't drive
[Laughter]
so the question is where did all this
money come from
i'm not saying she got rich off the
movement but the head of the new york
plm chapter
is demanding an independent
investigation into the finances
blm raised 100 million in donations from
corporations and
others see defining racism is a growth
industry
but she also signed a deal with warner
brothers a content production deal
good job warner brothers the content
she'll be producing will be how racist
warner brothers is
and just because you have brothers in
the name won't save you
i commend her real estate is a smart
investment i wish
when i was her age 37 i'd done the same
thing instead of spending all my money
on pokemon underwear
i thought they'd be collectibles turns
out only if you don't wear them
pirates
oh boy i knew you were coming to me you
know
here's the thing i know we like to hear
about how different we all are and how
whites and blacks are different than
hispanics and we're all different
but for some reason whenever we get
around
money we always end up the same
it's it's a phenomenon go to any
let's just take her out of it okay let's
just say we're going to start a church
the five little churches here and
we'll anoint greg pastor because he has
a passion to build the church and then
we get to church
and then people come to church and then
we go from one day a week church to five
days a week
and he's getting all the money and then
the rest of us are like hey
i would like a new no
it's important that i look the part of
being a part for the betterment of the
church
so it doesn't matter if you're a marxist
reverend
comedian it's all us together
until one of us gets paid
it does matter if you're a marxist
though because that's what i don't know
he's a cassius
i don't understand why anybody would
want to be a marxist not just
not just because it doesn't make sense
right but the best case scenario
is it works so well for you that you
become a hypocrite
yes like yeah well that's a good case
scenario you're a marxist when you don't
have it then when you've got it
you're a capitalist there's no such
thing as a successful marxist because
once you're a successful marcus
marxist you just become everything you
hated and you're a hypocrite
exactly and it happens to everybody who
who gets rich
they get a best-selling book and
suddenly they're buying real estate
emily
do you think people that gave money to
the black lives matter movement
might be pissed if they saw this no i
think they should give her money for the
airplane to go in the hangar
like the next go find me well to cat's
point actually
it's not so bad to be a marxist if you
end up as a hypocrite because there's
nobody in the media to call you out for
it so the hypocrisy doesn't really
matter
there's either two things going on here
first of all they either don't believe
what they're preaching or they either
completely don't understand it and
neither possibility is great from their
perspective but i would watch her show
on hgtv
really yes i think so yes yeah like a
marxist real estate
show it'd be uh it would be what are the
names of those shows
pete i don't watch tv uh i don't know
you
mouth tear this house down and replace
with a gulag
everyone has the same house everybody
has the same house coming up
it's a great prices one person wants to
deviate a little bit they're like
no how dare you
prices you shiplash your value just went
down uh
she is a by the way you made a hygiene
joke are you saying hand washing is a
thing now
yes it is you're the only person that
still doesn't wash hands
jury has been out on the hand-washing
debate
is the jury out yeah i don't know uh no
um
so i actually you are out hand-washing
denialists i
maybe you should take a selfie of you
washing your hands oh
i've been trying i haven't done that i
should take a selfie of me washing my
hands so then pete when he looks at my
instagram gotta go to cat tim's
instagram that'd be more like cat tim